our next topic deals with a beverage
commonly found in our fridges fruit
juice but just how much should kids be
drinking new recommendations were just
issued by the American Academy of
Pediatrics including juice consumption
guidelines for infants all the way up to
teens okay Tara so one of the buzziest
pieces of the recommendations here were
infant recommendations as far as fruit
juice what are they that's right so they
really took a tougher stance and they
the bottom line is that there is no
nutritional benefit for juice in infancy
and that parents should really be
avoiding giving juice to the child all
the way through their first year
why well the the juice can lead to
dental caries it has a lot of calories
excess sugar it can cause the child to
either gain too much weight or too
little weight and it can potentially
take away from milk or formula which
provides added proteins and fats and
vitamins and minerals so the
recommendation is pureed or mashed
fruits for children who are starting
solids and when you really do the math
you can see the difference is about four
ounces of juice 60 calories 13 grams of
sugar no fiber compared to a half a cup
of apple slices which is essentially 30
calories almost 6 grams of sugars almost
half and about a gram and a half of
fiber gap John what about older kids
well the idea is that that fruit juice
can be part of a balanced diet but you
don't want to be sucking the juice all
day long giving it in a sippy cup or a
bottle because it's so convenient to do
that and they specifically call out
parents who give a sippy cup or bottle
with fruit juice to try to calm down
their kid who's upset
guilty I have all been guilty hundred
percent done that I've done a sippy cup
myself yourself to calm you down but
they say if you're going to give juice
limited to from ages 1 to 3 limited to 4
ounces from 4 to 6 limited to 4 to 6
ounces and from 7 to 18 limited to 8
ounces but in general rather than having
the juice have the fruit that the juice
came from more fiber more filling Terry
there were also guidelines for
pediatricians what is the recommendation
I think the recommendation is that we as
a medical community need to do a better
job at educating about nutrition so one
of the big issues is to teach the
difference between fruit juice and fruit
drinks fruit juice 100% juice fruit
drinks anywhere from 10 to 99 percent
juice with added sweeteners flavorings
and
potentially other components in there
another thing that the pediatrician can
do is educate about the risk of dental
caries assess the children for their
level of nutrition and tell if they're
getting too much juice and also one of
the interesting points that brought up
is that when or if your child has a
gastrointestinal illness the instinct of
a lot of parents is to give juice to
rehydrate them that can actually make
the situation worse you can create a
syndrome symptom of carbohydrate
malabsorption and that can increase the
amount of diarrhea they're having dosent
sorbitol are particularly guilty exactly
so oral rehydration therapy is the way
to go if your kids get sick all right
finally making clothing breathable with
bacteria a study published this week in
the journal Science advances showcased
work done at MIT a research team
developed a breathable workout suit
that's lined with live bacteria which
react to body heat as well as sweat an
increase or decrease ventilation
accordingly the developers hope to
partner with sportswear companies and
maybe even include the material and
things like curtains and bed sheets this
is really amazing and they're talking
about adding other components of
functionality besides moisture
sensitivity that would make clothing for
instance fluoresce if you were running
at night or release a nice smelling odor
if you were sweating FMO
they haven't figured out though if you
can wash the clothes yet because the
bacteria may come off the fabric so one
point after yeah and I have to give a
shout out to our intrepid producer max
Goodman who every week puts this
together yes he goes through these
articles and figures out oh this would
be interesting and somehow this is very
interesting but he figured that out
based on the title he saw this title and
said oh that would be interesting
harnessing the hygroscopic and
biofluorescent behaviors are genetically
tractable microbial cells to design
bio-hybrid wearables and he thought that
way you think I wanted to this week go
max good real bad max right there all
right max I would have put that right in
the outbox all right doctors Jon LaPook
and Taryn Narula thank you both very
much